coffee on a Tuesday and black 34 so
you're annoyed with me yes I did drop
out of the universe there for a few
months with no explanation but I can
explain
in 2010 I graduated from college as a
film major and I was sure sure
then that I was going to be a filmmaker
for the rest of my life that summer I
made a film called I met you once in a
dream and I thought then it was gonna be
the next in the line of you know
hundreds of movies but that didn't work
out in the next few months I read a lot
of philosophy and wrote my discourse on
truth before leaving Boston with three
friends to take a u-shaped road trip
across the country and a blue Hyundai
Tucson I missed that car I moved to
Portland Oregon went through a small
teeny-tiny crisis of purpose worked on a
farm for a little while and came at the
other end a novel I grew a beard oh I
miss that beard I wrote my first book
big city which you can still buy on
Gumroad comm and I left Portland when
everyone I knew left it to then I was in
LA for a little while before moving to
Paris where I wrote my second book all
languages the Rose which is either dying
or dead and when I came back to the
states I moved back to LA and tried to
figure out how to public one day when I
got lost in a YouTube wormhole I
happened to discover the vlogbrothers
and I thought their videos were pretty
[ __ ] cool I figured out that John
Green was a novelist and he was selling
out printings because of his subscribers
on YouTube and I thought you know I can
do that so I did I started making videos
every week with an eye towards
publishing my books but after a while I
just started to want to make good
content for its own sake I really liked
this YouTube thing one day I was in a
cafe and I had this idea for a video for
the project for awesome on the kind of
um charity for getting kids desks in
Malawi which was actually created by the
last word with lawrence o'donnell on
MSNBC the video sort of blew up and they
heard about it and then they had me on
the show the night after I was on
Lawrence emailed me and asked me if I
want to go out for coffee so I said yes
yes yes he said you should move to New
York and do this video stuff for us and
since I was broke and since I was
working as a telemarketer which was
crushing my soul into the tiny teeny
tiny little bits of sharks tiny little
pieces of glass that were cutting me
from the inside and since I was broke
and this was basically a dream job I
accept it took a long time to work out
the particular and in working them out
and I disappeared from this vlog moved
to New York City started working at 30
rock for MSNBC doing this video stuff
which you can sometimes find here and
here
links in the doobly-doo and now that I
finally
settled in I sort of want to kind of
come back can I come back